[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video I just wanted to briefly
touch on some news that I heard
circulating around regarding the third
installment of the fantastic beasts
films the rumor which has yet to be
confirmed is suggesting that maybe just
maybe we'll see Hagrid and young Tom
Riddle in the upcoming films this is
something that I've always hoped for and
suspected and I think that it may be
true for a number of reasons number one
the timeline makes quite a lot of sense
the crimes of Grindelwald takes place in
the year 1927 and Grindelwald is still
very much on his rise to power the film
closes in this same year and Grindelwald
so has so much character development to
undergo as does everyone else Tom Riddle
starts of Hogwarts near 1938 and Hagrid
starts near in 1940 as Grindelwald isn't
actually defeated until the year 1945 it
would make total sense that these two
characters would make an appearance
number two Eddie Redmayne aka Newt
Scamander has expressed himself in a
reddit AMA that he'd like to see Hagrid
returned he was asked the question which
character would you like to see star in
fantastic beasts 3 to which red mane
replied with an enthusiastic Hagrid
Hagrid always Hagrid given that red mane
is such an important part of the
fantastic beasts films
it really does at least in my eyes give
me a glimmer of hope that perhaps Hagrid
and maybe even Tom Riddle will return
bearing all of that information in mind
we also need to remember that ultimately
there will be five fantastic beasts
films the second took place in 1927 and
I'm assuming that the last will take
place in 1945 this gives us quite a
large window of possibility and if
neither Hagrid nor Tom Riddle show up in
the second film
and I have no doubt they will show up
and at least the fourth or fifth to have
them not appear at all would be an
injustice with that time frame in mind
we can also speculate as to which other
characters we may see make an appearance
Moaning Myrtle immediately comes to mind
as she is the same age as Hagrid and
famously suffered at the hands of the
basilisk professor Horace Slughorn also
comes to mind as he was a professor at
Hogwarts during this time and famously
taught Tom Riddle if Tom Riddle is to
make an appearance I also suspect that
we will see that other members of his
gang who would later become Death Eaters
Dumbledore had this to say of follow
mort's gang that he formed while at
school they were a motley collection a
mixture of the weak seeking protection
the ambitious seeking some shared glory
and the thuggish gravitating toward a
leader who could show them more refined
forms of Cruelty we know that one of all
the mort's gang members is nameless
strange and I'm sure you guys can think
of a few other characters that share
this same last name perhaps this is the
father of Rudolph's one thing that's a
bit concerning about the film so far is
that they haven't been particularly
accurate as far as characters ages go as
a twenty-something Garnica is teaching
at Hogwarts in the year 1927
McGonigle was born in the year 1935 so
this doesn't make much sense
perhaps this McGonagall is simply
another McGonagall and not the one that
we're used to I'm really excited to see
how things unfold and which characters
they bring on board which other
characters do you guys think will see an
upcoming fantastic beasts films let me
know down in the comments section below
until next time you're away sorry
[Music]